lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
proponer una pregunta pero quisiera
mostrarles un vídeo para que hagamos
preguntas y análisis con respecto a este
vídeo aquí les estoy mostrando las
reglas de uso justo para material que no
es desarrollado este vídeo es de un
programa que se llama feef year y es de
un canal inglés channel fire el
propósito el carácter de uso incluyendo
si dicho uso es de naturaleza comercial
o si es con propósitos educativos sin
fines de lucro definitivamente caemos en
esta categoría porque es con fines
educativos 2 la naturaleza del trabajo
con derechos de autor 3 la cantidad y
sustancialidad de la parte usada en
relación con el trabajo registrado como
un todo aquí estamos usando una parte
muy pequeñita del vídeo lo necesario
para resolver nuestro problema
matemático tampoco vamos a poner audio
así que la cantidad es muy pequeña la
que vamos a usar 4 y el efecto del uso
sobre otros mercados potenciales o valor
del trabajo registrado es otra parte es
el núcleo central del uso justo un
crítico puedes citar justamente una gran
parte del trabajo original si es la
intención es real y verdaderamente el
usar los pasajes para
de crítica razonable y justa de hecho
aquí nosotros no vamos ni siquiera a
criticar vamos a usarlo con fines
educativos por otra parte es claro que
si se citan las partes más importantes
del trabajo no para criticar sino para
hacer prevalecer el uso del trabajo
original y dejar de lado la revisión de
este dicho uso se considera por la ley
como piratería aquí nosotros estamos
citando el trabajo original si ustedes
van a esta liga podrán ver el vídeo
completo como se mostró en este canal
original
en resumen debemos observar la
naturaleza y objetos de las elecciones
hechas la cantidad y valor de los
materiales usados y el grado en el cual
este uso podría perjudicar las ventas
disminuir las ganancias o reemplazar los
propósitos del trabajo original cosa que
aquí en ningún momento hacemos aquí
estamos viendo que es un piloto de
carreras y este piloto está conduciendo
este auto nosotros queremos saber a qué
velocidad va conduciendo este auto para
lograr la velocidad mínima necesaria
para que este auto haga un rizo o una
vuelta vertical qué es lo que vamos a
ver que realiza en este vídeo y luego
vamos a calcular cuál es la velocidad
promedio que realmente está usando este
vehículo para
y bueno procedemos a ver este vídeo
en ese momento está por entrar al rizo
aquí está marcando la velocidad que
lleva el auto
está por entre el rizo
en este instante está entrando
y sale de él perfectamente lo logro y
vamos a usar esto para resolver algunas
incógnitas matemáticas en el siguiente
vídeo esas interrogantes van a ser si
podemos encontrar cuál es la velocidad
mínima o debería decir cuál es la
magnitud de la velocidad mínima
necesaria para completar este rizo
vertical después usaremos un cronómetro
para encontrar cuál fue su velocidad
promedio